- Hey Legal Eagles!
It's time to adjudicate the matter
of Judge Kavanaugh vs.
Dr. Christine Blasey Ford.
(simple tonal music)
All right, let's think like a lawyer.
Like most of the country,
I've been glued to the
Kavanaugh/Ford hearings.
Regardless of what side
of the aisle you stand,
I think it raises important
questions for our country.
It also raises particular legal issues
that I think deserve a thorough debate.
So, today I'd like to give
you the first real law review
of the Kavanaugh/Ford hearing
from the perspective of a lawyer.
This will be the first in a
new series on this channel
where I try to tackle
the most important
legal issues of the day.
If you have a suggestion
for the next legal topic I should cover,
please leave that down below
and if you disagree with me,
be sure to leave your comment
in the form of an objection.
And, by the way, if you'd like to see me
critique your favorite legal TV show,
like Suits or Better Call Saul,
check out my Real Lawyer Reacts series,
the link for that will be down below.
Now, there are five questions
that I want to cover today.
Number one: Did Judge
Kavanaugh commit legal perjury?
Number two: Did he display
a judge-like temperament?
Number three: Would
Judge Kavanaugh prevent
investigations into President
Trump or the White House?
Number four: Would the current allegations
of sexual assault hold up in court?
And number five: Should Judge
Kavanaugh have requested
an investigation by the FBI?
Now, before we begin, on a personal note,
this is not meant to
be a partisan analysis.
I'm not gonna give you
my opinion on whether
I think Judge Kavanaugh should be elevated
to the Supreme Court based
on his judicial philosophy
or his political views.
I'm a lawyer first and
that's the perspective
I'm going to try to give you.
Oh, and one last thing.
This is Stella the Legal Beagle.
She reads all of your comments.
Now, I want this to be a hearty debate,
but I want it to be a civil debate.
If you wouldn't say it in front of Stella,
please reword it so that
it's Stella-appropriate.
All right, so with that out
of the way, let's begin.
So, question number one, did
Judge Kavanaugh commit perjury?
Now, perjury is a very specific crime.
Taken from Title 18 of the US Code,
perjury is defined as having taken an oath
before a competent tribunal
that he will testify truly
and contrary to such
oath states or subscribes
any material matter which he
does not believe to be true.
Now, looking at a lot of the
footage from the hearing,
it seems to me that a lot
of Judge Kavanaugh's answers
appeared to be evasive and non-responsive.
For example, Judge Kavanaugh was asked
what ralphing referred to
in the context of Beach Week
and he defined as referring to
his chronically weak stomach
from eating spicy food
and that he can't really
keep his food down.
- Let's look at Beach Week
Ralph Club Biggest Contributor,
what does the word ralph mean in that?
- That probably refers to throwing up,
I'm known to have a weak
stomach and I always have.
In fact, the last time I was here,
you asked me about having
ketchup on spaghetti,
I always have had a weak stomach.
- Judge Kavanaugh was asked
to define Devil's Triangle,
as it appeared in his yearbook.
He defined Devil's
Triangle as a drinking game
and not any kind of sexual act.
- Devil's Triangle?
- (sniffles) Drinking game.
- How's it played?
- Three glasses in a triangle.
- And?
- You ever played Quarters?
- Nope.
- Okay, it's a Quarters game.
- Judge Kavanaugh was also asked to define
Renate alumnus as it
appears in his yearbook.
He explains that that
refers to being friends
with a woman who went to
a neighboring high school.
- You mentioned, I think, the
Renate, or Renate, Renata,
I don't know how you pronounce that,
that's a proper name of
an individual you know?
- Renate.
It's spelled with an E at the
end, R-E-N-A-T-E, is that--
- Correct.
- Okay.
And then after that is
the word "alumnius."
What does the word "alumnius"
mean in that context?
- I explained that in
my opening statement.
We, she was a great friend of ours.
A bunch of us went to dances with her,
she hung out with us as a group.
The media circus that has
been generated by this thought
and reported that it
referred to sex, it did not.
- Now, given that I was
once a 17-year-old boy,
it seems to me that a lot of these answers
are evasive at best and
flat-out wrong in the worst case
and that a lot of these
terms simply don't jive
with the common understanding
of a lot of the way
that these words would be used.
Some seem unrealistic.
But perjury requires a
very specific mens rea
that you knowingly state something
that is false under oath.
It's possible that he and his friends
had very idiosyncratic definitions
of some of these words,
perhaps they were taken out of context,
and on top of that, it would
be very difficult to find
a definitive guide on what
these words actually mean.
Language is always changing.
But I think a lot of the problems stem
from the Democratic
senators failing to pin
Judge Kavanaugh down to
an actual definition.
If you were to think of this
hearing like a deposition,
the point is not necessarily to argue
or get a Perry Mason-like admission,
but to lock down the witness
into a specific story
and a specific definition.
You lock them down so they can't back out
and you can go down the rabbit hole
to show how ridiculous it is.
Now, normally you don't
ask the witness questions
you don't know the answer to,
but if you know that the answers
are going to be fairly ridiculous,
then you want the witness to explain
all of the repercussions that come
from the idiosyncratic or ridiculous view
that they're taking and
so you wanna take them
down that road and take it to an extreme
to show how ridiculous it seems.
Here, a lot of the Democratic senators
failed to ask follow-up questions
that would've pinned down Judge Kavanaugh.
For example, when he refers
to the Devil's Triangle
as a drinking game,
you could really pin him down
to show how ridiculous that is.
You could say that, "It's your testimony
"that the Devil's Triangle
is a drinking game, correct?"
You get a yes answer.
"It's your testimony
that the Devil's Triangle
"does not refer to a
sexual act of some kind?"
He'll probably answer no.
"It's your testimony
that the Devil's Triangle
"does not refer to a sexual act
"with one woman and two men?"
He'll probably answer no again.
The senators could've followed
up about his weak stomach.
They could've asked if he throws up
every time he has spicy food.
They could've asked when was the last time
he had Indian food, when was the last time
he had Mexican food, Cajun food,
and just go down the line.
And, granted, they might not
be able to get him to admit
that maybe he has spicy food
more often than he lets on
and maybe he doesn't vomit
every time he has it,
and that the vomiting
probably relates to drinking
more than it does to having a
quote-unquote "weak stomach,"
but what they can do is lay the foundation
to catch him in falsehoods later on.
That's one of the big issues
with this particular hearing
is that a lot of the
senators were trying to argue
at the same time they were
trying to ask questions
and as any trial lawyer will tell you,
you can not argue at the same
time you're asking questions.
Those are two separate functions
that need to be separated.
So the Democratic senators
should have done a better job
of separating the cross-examinations
from the arguments
to do a better job of
laying the foundation
for catching Judge Kavanaugh
in outright falsehoods.
As in court, one's character
for telling the truth
on the stand is almost always relevant
and if you lay the foundation,
just getting out facts
that don't seem reasonable,
then perhaps after the hearing is finished
you can go do some investigations
and find evidence that contradicts
what Judge Kavanaugh stated on the stand
and I suspect if they had asked
better follow-up questions,
they would've been able to do that.
And if we're thinking about
these particular questions
as a cross-examination,
like what would happen in
trial, a lot of the questioners
allowed the witness to evade the question.
They fell for the witness' obfuscation
and abandoned their original question.
And as any ligator will tell you,
if you don't get an answer to
the question that you asked,
you ask that exact question again
and you ask that exact question
until you get the answer
that you're looking for.
So, for example, when
Judge Kavanaugh was asked,
"Would you want Mark Judge
to testify on your behalf?"
The Senator asked the same question once,
but then he abandons that question
to then argue with the witness,
falling for the trap of
wasting his time on argument
instead of following up
with the exact question.
- If she's saying Mark
Judge was in the room then,
then he should be in the room here today.
Would you want him called as a witness?
- Senator, this allegation
came into the committee--
- Oh no, no, I'm just asking the question,
would you want him to
be here as a witness?
- He's already provided sworn
testimony to the committee.
This allegation's been
hidden by the committee--
- No, it's hasn't been--
- by members of the committee.
- It has not been investigated by the FBI,
the committee has refused
to allow it to be--
- It was dropped on me, it was sprung--
- It was not investigated by the FBI
and he was not been called
where he might be under oath--
- Shoulda been handled in
the due course, senator,
when it came in.
- I would disagree with that.
I've been on this committee 44 years.
- I think if the senator had asked
the same question again
in the correct way,
I think he would've
gotten a yes or no answer.
But the fact is, you can't argue
and question at the same time.
If the witness is non-responsive,
you have to stop the testimony
and make them answer.
Now, in trial, you have the advantage
of having the judge there to
force the witness to answer.
Here, of course, there is no neutral judge
to force the witness to answer,
you can't object as non-responsive
and get the judge to step in
and make the witness answer.
And the witness here, Judge Kavanaugh,
has every incentive to waste
as much time as possible
knowing that the senators only have
five minutes for each person.
Despite the witness having
every incentive to waste time,
there are plenty of
tactics that you can use
to get the witness to answer yes or no.
Now, first of all, you have
to ask a yes or a no question.
This doesn't work unless you
ask very pointed questions,
which a lot of the senators failed to do.
But, if you are phrasing
your questions correctly
in the form of a yes or no question,
and the witness is still non-responsive,
here's an example of what you can do.
You can say, "Thank you for that answer,
"but my question was different.
"My question was," and then
just repeat your question.
And then if the witness
is still non-responsive,
then you escalate it.
You interrupt the witness and say,
"I'm sorry, the question that I asked was,
"yes or no," blank and
then reask the question.
Now, if you have more time,
then you can try and get
the witness on your side
by explaining that you're trying
to get an answer to your question
and that the other side
will have the opportunity
to allow you to expound on your answer,
but you're just asking
for a yes or no question.
So, I don't want this to seem
like it should just be an
incredibly aggressive process,
it sort of depends on the witness,
but there are a ton of rhetorical devices
that you can use to
get yes or no responses
to accurately phrased questions.
And here, unfortunately,
I don't think a lot of
the Democratic senators
had much trial experience
and didn't have a lot of
the rhetorical devices
in their pocket that they should have.
All right, so let's think like a lawyer
in regards to this question.
In other words, let's try to come up
with the strongest arguments
on both sides of this issue.
I think the Democrats would argue
that these answers don't comport
with anyone's reasonable expectation
of these particular words
and the only explanation
is that Judge Kavanaugh is
trying to avoid the truth
in order to get through this hearing.
They don't comport with common experience
and they are not accurate
representations of these words.
I think that the Republican response
would be that the Democratic senators
failed to ask good
cross-examination questions,
they failed to pin down the witness,
they allowed the witness
to evade the questions
and give the answers
that he wanted to give
and failed to pin down the witness
to a particular answer that qualifies
as the legal definition of perjury.
Now, there is a separate question
as to whether a nominee
should evade questions
and obfuscate, but that brings
us to our second question,
did Judge Kavanaugh display
a judge-like temperament?
Now, any judge holds a
special position in society.
They are the arbiters of our disputes.
Theoretically, they
should all be impartial.
They need to be able to hear both sides
and make judgment calls
that have a huge effect
on the litigants' lives.
Now, Justices of the Supreme
Court are appointed for life
and they hold an even
higher place in our society,
they literally make life or
death decisions sometimes.
So, it's not surprising that
both judges and justices
are held to a very, very high standard.
They are supposed to be neutral,
they are not supposed to
take a partisan stance,
they are supposed to be able to be
the neutral arbiters of
our general disputes.
In his opening statement,
Judge Kavanaugh made some
very provocative statements
about the backlash being
a result of revenge from the Clintons.
- This whole two week
effort has been a calculated
and orchestrated political hit,
fueled with apparent pent up anger
about President Trump
and the 2016 election,
fear that has been unfairly
stoked about my judicial record,
revenge on behalf of the Clintons,
and millions of dollars
in money from outside,
left-wing opposition groups.
This is a circus.
- Judge Kavanaugh also
got into a sparing match
with Senator Klobuchar when
she asked about past drinking.
- I think you've probably
had beers, Senator, and--
- So you're saying
there's never been a case
where you drank so much
that you didn't remember
what happened the night before
or part of what happened?
- It's, you're asking
about, yeah, black out,
I don't know, have you?
- Could you answer the question, Judge?
I just, so have, that's not happened?
Is that your answer?
- Yeah and I'm curious if you have.
- (chuckles) I have no
drinking problem, Judge.
- Yeah, nor do I.
- Okay, thank you.
- And Judge Kavanaugh also
got into some sparing matches
with other senators about
some pointed questions.
- Did the word ralph, you
used in your yearbook--
- I already said, I already
answered the question.
If you're, yeah--
- Did it relate to alcohol--
- I like beer.
- You haven't answered that.
- I don't know if you do--
- Okay.
- Do you like beer, Senator, or not?
What do you like to drink?
- Next one is--
- Senator, what do you like to drink?
- Judge, have you--
- So, let's think like a lawyer.
I think the Democrats would probably argue
that this shows a character
for not being impartial,
for taking partisan stances,
and that his hot-headedness
shows that he doesn't have the temperament
to be a Supreme Court Justice,
who we hold to a very, very high standard.
Not to say anything of the
allegations of sexual assault
that have given rise
to this whole hearing.
I think the Republicans
would probably respond
that he should not have been
asked these questions in the first place,
that they weren't proper to begin with,
and that he is understandably angry
for being put in this position.
Now, I think we can make another
parallel to some trial law.
As a rule of evidence,
generally character evidence
is not admissible at trial,
but the main exception
is where the accused
has made character an issue
and they usually do that by calling
a bunch of witnesses to explain
how good of a person they are
and how they never could have
done the underlying crime.
Now, here Judge Kavanaugh
has done something similar,
he has essentially said that
he was not a heavy drinker,
he has never blacked out,
he has never used sexual slang
in the context that he's alleged,
and he has never engaged in
inappropriate sexual behavior.
In some ways, if we were to
draw a parallel to a trial,
this has opened the door
to test his veracity for truthfulness
and also to show whether
the superlative statements
that he is making are true or not.
So, do you think that Judge Kavanaugh
displayed a judge-like behavior?
Let me know, I leave it to you.
Now, that takes me to issue number three,
would Judge Kavanaugh, if
elevated to the Supreme Court,
prevent an investigation
into the president or the White House?
Now, a lot of pundits have argued
that Judge Kavanaugh, in particular,
was nominated to the Supreme Court
because he holds an idiosyncratic view
that the sitting president
can not be indicted civilly or criminally.
A lot of this stems from
a law review article
that he wrote in the Minnesota Law Review
called the Separation of Powers
During the Forty-Fourth
Presidency and Beyond.
In that law review piece,
Judge Kavanaugh argued that
Congress should pass a law
that while the president is in office,
he should not be subject to civil lawsuits
or to criminal investigation
or prosecution.
He explained that based on
his first-hand experience
in the White House, he came to believe
that the job of the president is,
"far more difficult than any other
"civil position in government."
And he also says that the president
must be able to focus on
the tasks of being president
and shouldn't be distracted
by civil or criminal trials.
Judge Kavanaugh recognized
the irony of his position,
given that he started his legal career
in the Independent Counsel's
Office with Kenneth Starr
during the Clinton
impeachment investigation
and he imposed exactly
the kinds of burdens
that he's saying a sitting president
should not have to deal with.
So, let's think like a
lawyer about this position.
I think the Republicans would argue
that the Supreme Court
is supposed to decide
what is mandated by the Constitution
and they should not let their
individual policy preferences
guide their decision making.
A Supreme Court Justice
is supposed to interpret the Constitution
and not make policy by fiat,
and I think the Republicans would argue
that this law review piece is advocating
that Congress pass a law
and not that there is a
Constitutional mandate
for this particular policy position
and, in fact, Judge Kavanaugh
has made statements to that effect,
that he recognizes his policy preference
is not mentioned in the Constitution
and it may contradict
what's in the Constitution
and therefore his stance
as a sitting Justice
on the Supreme Court is not informed
by this particular law review article,
or the policies that he advocated.
I think the Democrats would argue
that while that's nice in theory,
isn't it funny how
often policy preferences
line up with one's own personal theory
of what the Constitution
mandates, what it says,
and what needs to be interpreted
as a result of the Constitution.
Upon being elevated to the Supreme Court,
they suddenly find a textual reason
for their particular policy preference.
The bottom line is, I don't
think we know for certain
which way Judge Kavanaugh would rule
if he was elevated to the Supreme Court.
You could argue both ways,
based on his prior statements.
So that takes us to question number four,
would Dr. Christine
Blasey Ford's allegations
of sexual assault hold up in court?
And other wise, could they lead
to Judge Kavanaugh being
convicted of sexual assault?
Now, criminal law has the
highest burden under the law.
The prosecution, in other words,
the people making the claim,
must prove their case
beyond a reasonable doubt.
Now, the accused technically
has no burden at all.
If the prosecution
doesn't meet their burden,
then the defendant should
not have to make any showing
in order to avoid conviction.
So, to decide if the allegations
would hold up in court,
we need to look at the evidence.
Now, there is one statement
that I see coming up in the news a lot,
that I think we should talk about.
A lot of pundits have argued
that there is no evidence
of sexual assault.
One of my biggest pet peeves as a lawyer
is when people refer to a
he said/she said scenario
and refer to it as if
there is no evidence.
Even if there is only he said/she said
with no physical evidence,
there is, in fact, evidence
in the form of testimony.
Imagine if you had a police
officer who testified
that she saw a bank robber rob a bank.
The bank robber could deny that
and technically that is a
he said/she said scenario.
But, I bet you would probably think
the first-hand testimony
of the police officer
was pretty strong evidence
and, in fact, often you
get people talking about
circumstantial versus direct evidence
and this is another one of big pet peeves.
Circumstantial evidence is evidence
that relies on an inference
in order to connect it
to a conclusion of fact,
for example, DNA evidence
at the scene of a crime.
By contrast, direct evidence supports
the truth of an assertion directly
without the need for additional
evidence or inference.
So, I don't mean to imply
that circumstantial evidence
is ever inherently bad or weak,
often circumstantial evidence
is the strongest evidence that there is,
but in this particular case,
we happen to have direct evidence,
we have Dr. Christine
Blasey Ford's testimony.
Now, you may believe her testimony
or you may not believe her testimony,
but if this were a court of law
that would still qualify
as particular evidence.
It would be direct evidence in the form
of her particular first-hand testimony
of what happened to her in 1983.
So, as a threshold
matter, there is evidence.
There is evidence on the side
of Dr. Christine Blasey Ford
in the form of her testimony
and there is evidence on
the side of Judge Kavanaugh
in the form of his direct testimony
and that is separate from the question
of whether Dr. Ford's
testimony would meet the burden
of beyond a reasonable doubt.
I don't know how a jury would
come out on this question,
but as we discussed with perjury,
I'm not sure that whether something meets
the technical legal definition
and the hurdle of beyond
a reasonable doubt
is really beside the point or not.
So that brings me to question number five,
should Judge Kavanaugh have
requested an investigation?
During the hearing,
the Democratic senators
asked a lot of questions
of Judge Kavanaugh
asking if he would be in favor
of a further FBI
investigation into his conduct
and what Dr. Ford alleges happened to her.
- So I'm gonna ask you one last time,
are you willing to ask the White House
to authorize the FBI to
investigate the claims
that have been made against you?
- I'll do whatever the
Committee wants, of course--
- [Senator Harris] And I've
heard you say that, but--
- The witness statements--
- I've not heard you ask--
I've not heard you answer
a very specific question
that's been asked,
which is are you willing
to ask the White House
to conduct an investigation by the FBI
to get to whatever you believe
is the bottom of the allegations
that have been levied against you?
- And whether he should have
requested an FBI investigation
probably depends on your
definition of should.
As an attorney, I can't
imagine a situation
where I counsel a client to ask
for a further investigation
of that client.
Speaking as an attorney,
it's usually not a good idea
to encourage an investigation
into your client
and just because you don't
have anything to hide
doesn't mean you have anything
you actively want to share.
But that particular legal advice
would have no bearing
in this particular case
as to whether calling for an investigation
would be a good PR move
or whether it is the
morally right thing to do.
I'll leave that to the moral philosophers
because this is not a legal question,
this is a political,
ethical, and moral question
and, in general, you don't
wanna ask your lawyer
for philosophical advice.
So, do you agree?
Leave your objections in the comments
and let me know what other
pressing legal issues
I should cover next.
And as always, I see you in court.